will you assign female you make really
clear that I am NOT a woman in a man's
body
I am a woman I've always been a woman
it's 2019 and you know what that means
men can get pregnant too naturally it's
an accepted scientific fact among
today's progressive left that whatever
you were born with doesn't matter you
choose whether you're a man or woman
it's not correct that there is such a
thing as biological sex it's the biggest
one for me is when I hear a man who
wants to be a woman and vice versa they
don't want to be a woman they don't want
to be a man they are excuse me it's
ma'am it is ma'am no you're probably out
honey
no it's a world out here and considering
the Planned Parenthood as America's
self-proclaimed number one provider of
women's health care we wanted to see
just how all-in they are it's true I'm
Stephanie and I'm pretty sure I'm
pregnant so my partner Garrett and I are
going to Planned Parenthood to get
ourselves so that Plan B so we decided
to start small and see if they'd give
Stephanie some good old Plan B we wanted
to talk to someone about Plan B can I
purchase that angers debt with you I
don't even speak with a doctor oh okay
to be fair they could have thought that
stephanie was picking up the plan B for
someone else thank you so much innocent
perfection might happen
so the food is just really first time we
come stepping outside of that that's or
actually in the case of a man
infertility loss of libido and erectile
dysfunction someone's gonna have a tummy
ache Sean they plan to show them your
plan B we're gonna take care of this now
a little research turned up the Planned
Parenthood America self-proclaimed
number one provider of women's health
care and recipient of five hundred and
twenty eight million tax dollars
annually have actually made it a part of
their policy to treat transgender
patients as any other woman even going
as far as issuing these official
guidelines so Stephanie decided to see
just how far this newfound medical
tolerance extends but oh I don't think
that plan B worked
I still feel super pregnant isn't she
glowing so we decided to go to another
Planned Parenthood to get our official
pregnancy test so Stephanie and
quarterblack Garrett scheduled a
pregnancy test along with a follow up
with a nurse practitioner and for good
measure we brought the urine of an
actually pregnant woman along with us
just to see how far the tolerance
extends beyond you know medicine now I
know this may seem childish and stupid
on the outset but keep in mind that
while a positive pregnancy test for a
woman can come as great news for a man
it's largely indicative of testicular
cancer - a Planned Parenthood do the
responsible thing and let a man know
that he could have potentially
life-threatening cancer or stick to
their progressive guns and follow their
code of conduct in regards to
transgender patients now keep in mind
that this video has been edited both for
time and maximum polarity
the suspense is killing me
also the testicular cancer really the
only options we can give you is that we
can give you the forms for the Medicaid
if you want to go ahead and continue
with the pregnancies okay give it up for
adoption sure the option of termination
we don't do them here okay you don't
know from those here yeah we got well
it's good to know that there are options
now to be fair the nurse practitioner
did have some questions and was
seemingly concerned with potential
health ramifications as you can see they
can't even play by their own guidelines
do you mean if I was misgendered by a
doctor when I was born did they consider
you a female when you were born I was
misgendered at birth you okay I don't
see how that's I mean do you have
ovaries but a little righteous
indignation threw her off the scent we
make really clear that I am NOT a woman
in a man's body I am a woman I've always
been a woman and I'm currently living as
a woman so they did identify me they
misgendered me as a meal when I was a
boy okay or are these questions that are
asked of every woman who comes in here
yes yes they have ovaries if they take
testosterone I'm asking yeah I'm not
gonna let any medications okay okay
after all gotta get back to that
handbook and thank God at no point was
there any mention of potential
testicular cancer so it's a positive
test
I want to make okay yes okay good it's a
clear answer okay good yeah it's not one
of those kind of purple maybe blue
it was definitely it was back okay so
there's a scale of how dark it is I'm
not far along and I go by that but okay
the thinner the line is it's usually
lower hormone and but no you can't
actually go by that full day sure that
it's not like it's everything okay yeah
it's definitely okay positive so okay
come on up to the front
yay no ball cancer here I'm just
pregnant it's official we're pregnant
also we met this poor bastard this one
line broke and she's like go they told
me it clears up pretty pretty fast
yes I'm sure they told you that yes yeah
I mean if you could do it I mean I know
it's not easy obviously but it's it's
not as bad as you might think it is if
that helps I just found out I'm pregnant
I guess congratulation not so fast
okay so after that scheduled sonogram I
will return for the termination
procedure exactly okay perfect
nope thank you very much I appreciate it
see you then hey there if you like this
video subscribe to the channel or hit
the notification bell do it I'll wait a
second do your that little ding it
actually didn't make a ding sound I just
did it happen while my mouth was doing
it and you thought it was coming from
your computer ah so that's fun
also there's some videos playing in
these boxes next to me go watch those
you might enjoy them you might not you
don't care